.
* Rascheln, Monotone Klänge *
(Mann) "Surprise" - Strassenmagazin.
Schau!
- Danke!
Etwa vor zehn Jahren fing ich an,
hier im Tageshaus für Obdachlose
den Menschen die Haare zu schneiden.
Es interessierte mich richtig,
was für Menschen ich
auf der Strasse wahrnehme.
Was haben sie erlebt?
Was haben sie für Geschichten?
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Harold, hallo.
Hallo, zusammen.
- Bonjour.
Du darfst gerne hier Platz nehmen.
Wie immer? Oben länger
und auf der Seite kürzer?- Genau.
Oben vielleicht so viel ...
Ziemlich kurz.
Dann sind die Locken weg.
Nicht unbedingt, je nachdem.
- Ich lasse sie etwas länger.- Ja.
* Polizeisirene im Hintergrund *
Musst du heute nicht arbeiten?
- Nein.
Es ist etwas chaotisch im Moment.
- Okay.
Aber du bist immer noch dran?
Ja.
Und deine Wohnsituation?
Hat sie sich verändert?
Nein.
Ich bin immer noch
in der Notschlafstelle.
Jetzt habe ich einige Tage in Lies-
tal bei einem Freund übernachtet.
Du bist schon zwei Jahre
in der Notschlafstelle?- Ja.
* Melancholische Klänge,
Surren des Haartrimmers *
* Bellen *
Ich bin Schweizer, bin noch jung
und ich habe einen Sohn.
Ich bin seit zwei Jahren
ohne Wohnung.
Ich habe die Zähne zusammengebissen,
das Maximum gegeben und trotzdem ...
Ich habe Schulden.
Mein Lohn wird gepfändet.
Ich komme nicht mehr raus
aus der ganzen Scheisse.
Es dauert nicht mehr lang und ich
schmeisse alles hin und haue ab.
Ich geh weg,
weil mich das System einfach nervt.
Ich muss noch mit dir sprechen.
Es ist wichtig, was gestern
mit den Lehrern besprochen wurde.
Du musst versuchen,
ein starker Junge zu sein.
Und heute hast du Frisbee?
Möchtest du, dass ich mitkomme
oder wie willst du es machen?
Wenn du mitkommst,
geht's schneller.
Also, schön aufmerksam sein
und lernen, ja?
Bisous, mein Schatz.
Tschau!
* Melancholische Klänge *
Ich bin eigentlich
wie ein Fluchttier.
Schon damals lief ich
von Frankreich weg.
Vom Haus meiner Mutter.
Weglaufen, das kann ich nämlich gut.
(Mann) "Surprise" - Strassenmagazin.
"Surprise" - Strassenmagazin.
* Strassenlärm *
Du hast lange draussen gelebt, oder?
Ja, richtig. Sehr lang.
Es war eine sehr harte Zeit,
rund neuneinhalb Jahre.
Bei der Stadtmauer
war ich achteinhalb Jahre.
Wann kommt der Punkt,
an dem du merkst,
dass du wieder eine Wohnung,
ein anderes Leben möchtest?
Irgendwann hat man es satt,
so zu leben.
Tagsüber immer unterwegs,
jedem
und allem ausgeliefert.
Wenn das so überhandnimmt,
muss man etwas ändern.
Wie warst du unterwegs?
V.a. allein?
Ja, man ist eigentlich nur allein.
Wenn man verheiratet ist,
ist man irgendwie auch allein.
Man spricht miteinander,
kommuniziert,
lebt aber irgendwie
doch für sich allein.
Vielleicht habe ich eine merkwürdige
Ansicht. Ich empfinde es so.
Es kann anders sein.
Ich lebe seit 35 Jahren allein,
ich kenne leider nichts anderes.
Du bist ein Einzelkämpfer?
Ja, natürlich.
Meine Geschichte zeigt das ja.
* Angestrengtes Atmen *
V.a. als Kind und Jugendlicher muss-
te ich auf sehr vieles verzichten.
Das wirkt sich aufs ganze Leben aus.
* Aufheulen des Spielautomotors *
Ich habe Freude, es macht Freude!
Oje.
* Eindringliche Klänge *
* Schluchzen *
Was jedes Kleinkind
von den Eltern lernt,
Liebe und alles, Geborgenheit.
Das hatte ich nie. Nie.
Deshalb hänge ich an diesem Scheiss.
An Drogen und solcher Scheisse.
"Surprise" - Strassenmagazin.
* Strassenlärm, dumpfe Klänge *
Ich brauche sehr wenig Schlaf.
3-4 Std. pro Tag reichen mir.
Das ist so,
seit ich ein junges Mädchen war.
Mir gefallen die Lichter nachts.
Ich geniesse die Ruhe.
Dann habe ich Ruhe.
Die Einsamkeit
zog mich meistens runter.
Niemanden zu haben.
Niemanden, der eine Ahnung hat, wie
es ist, als Frau obdachlos zu sein.
* Die Tür quietscht. *
Mir wurde bewusst, was es heisst,
nichts mehr zu haben.
Nichts mehr. Wirklich nichts mehr.
* Monotone, brummende Klänge *
Ich legte immer Wert
auf ein anständiges Äusseres.
Ich komme aus einer Armutsfamilie,
meine Mutter brachte mir das bei.
Wie hast du das draussen gemacht?
Du hast deine Haare gepflegt, oder?
Kommt darauf an, wo draussen.
Wenn man nur im Freien ist,
ohne einen Ort
zum Duschen oder Haarpflegen,
dann geht man an einen Brunnen
oder in ein öffentliches WC.
Aber im Winter
friert einem fast das Gehirn ab.
Am Anfang konnte ich mich mit
dem Gassenleben nicht anfreunden.
Man kommt aus der behüteten Zone
und muss plötzlich auf der Strasse
oder neben fünf anderen Frauen
schlafen.
Ich musste alle Lebensstationen
durchgehen und aufräumen.
Ich musste auch wissen,
weshalb ich so abgestürzt bin,
weshalb ich alles abgebrochen habe.
Ich bin eigentlich davongelaufen.
Genau betrachtet
lief ich aus dieser Ehe
und liess meine Söhne
und meinen Mann im Stich.
Genau betrachtet.
* Monotone Klänge *
Geht's dir gut?
- Ja. Dir, wie geht's?
Auch gut, ich bin zufrieden.
Wo schläfst du jetzt?
Auf der Gasse?
Ich sprach verachtend
über solche Menschen.
Und zwar ...
- Was für Menschen?
Menschen mit einer Sucht. Egal was.
Die nicht mehr im System
mitarbeiten können.
* Unverständliche Worte *
Hä?
- Noch 11 Min.
Elf?
So lernte ich
die Menschen kennen,
wie sie wirklich sind,
ihre Geschichten.
Und ich musste meine Meinung
um 180 °C ändern.
Man kann schnell in die Armut
abrutschen, es braucht wenig.
Ich war sehr arrogant und dachte,
jeder sei selbst schuld
an seiner Misere und, und, und.
Aber das stimmte einfach nicht.
Guten Appetit.
- Du ...
Das reicht für heute.
Man schämt sich
über seine Situation.
Durch die Jahre draussen verliert
man sehr an Selbstsicherheit.
Das ist beinahe fliessend.
Man traut sich sehr wenig zu,
immer weniger mit der Zeit.
Man fühlt sich abgedrängt,
man gehört zu einer Minderheit
und kommt gar nicht mehr da raus.
* Strassenlärm *
Ich möchte einfach mitmachen,
akzeptiert und dabei sein.
Das ist mir wichtig.
* Kindergeschrei,
nachdenkliche Musik *
Ich habe oft gesehen,
dass ich in einer Lage bin,
die nicht richtig ist.
Ich schäme mich.
Das ist eines meiner Hauptprobleme:
sich für viele Sachen zu schämen.
Vielleicht habe ich mir zu wenig
Mühe gegeben in meiner Beziehung.
Es ist einfach so:
Ich habe auch einen Stolz.
Ein Ego.
Nach der Trennung
ging es mir nicht gut.
Ich konnte meinen Sohn
sieben Monate lang nicht sehen.
Trotzdem arbeitete ich weiter,
Tag für Tag.
Meine Kollegen schauten live zu,
wie ich in diesen paar Monaten
abgestürzt bin.
Ich machte Fehler,
vergass viel bei der Arbeit.
Mir wurde gekündigt.
Weil ich die Miete nicht zahlen
konnte, verlor ich die Wohnung.
In solchen Momenten
glaubt man nicht mehr an sich.
Man verliert den Boden ...
* Schwungvolle Akkordeonmusik *
(Mann) "Surprise" - Strassenmagazin.
"Surprise" - Strassenmagazin.
* Strassenlärm, Akkordeonmusik,
Stimmengewirr *
Du weisst, ich erzählte dir
schon mal von früher.
Mein Werdegang ist ja recht kurios
und ich habe immer gearbeitet.
Mhm.
Heute bereue ich es eigentlich.
Ich habe zwei Söhne,
die ich eigentlich kaum kenne.
Ich arbeitete viel zu viel, 60 %.
Am Ende 100 %, als sie älter waren.
Da verliert man ... Etwas leidet.
Man kann nicht arbeiten,
die Familie
durchorganisiert behalten
und gleichzeitig noch
eine Weiterbildung machen.
Das habe ich auch noch gemacht -
und rutschte in ein Burnout.
* Strassenlärm, beklemmende Musik *
Du hattest vielleicht
einfach das Bedürfnis, zu arbeiten,
dich weiterzuentwickeln.
Ja, wenn man unzufrieden ist,
reicht einem das, was man hat, nie.
Ich war so unzufrieden,
dass ich immer auf der Suche
nach Reichtum war.
* Strassenlärm, Stimmengewirr *
Wenn man
ein straffes Programm hat ...
Wenn alles so gestrafft ist,
bleibt einem keine Zeit mehr.
Aber das ist antrainiert, anerzogen,
seit ich ein Kind bin.
Und dann merkte ich,
wenn ich mich nicht geändert hätte,
gäbe es mich heute
vielleicht nicht mehr.
Deshalb bin ich eigentlich
ausgestiegen.
Mit Gelegenheitsjobs konnte ich
die Miete nicht mehr bezahlen.
Nach einem Jahr
räumte die Polizei die Wohnung
und ich musste lernen,
was es heisst,
nur noch zwei Koffer
und einen Rucksack zu haben.
* Poltern *
Heute arbeitest du nicht?
Nein. Morgen fliege ich nach Afrika.
- Was?
Wohin?
- Nach Kamerun.
Nach Kamerun gehst du?
- Ja.
Morgen früh.
-Morgen früh?
Du geiler Kerl!
- Flieg ich weg.
Ich gehe arbeiten.
Tschüss, Urs.
- Mach's gut.
Pass auf dich auf.
- Du auch.
Bist ein guter Typ.
Also, schönen Tag!
- Tschüss!
Darf ich dir die Haare
kürzer schneiden, Urs?
Ja, ja.
Ziemlich kurz?- Ja, ja.
- Okay.
Es ist mutig, einfach zu gehen,
ohne ...
Ja, aber ich bin so aufgewachsen,
mit einfachen Dingen.
Als du Kind warst, meinst du?
- Ja.
Wir hatten kein Wasser im Haus,
und das WC war auch draussen.
Hattest du eine glückliche Kindheit?
- Ja, sehr.
Immer mit Arbeit,
aber sonst war sie gut.
Wie stellst du dir
das Leben in Kamerun vor?
Hast du eine Vorstellung?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich passe mich ihnen an.
Hast du ein Zimmer für dich allein?
- Ja.
Sie haben ein Gästezimmer,
das ich benutzen kann.
Dort geht es nicht anders.
Man kann nicht draussen sein -
nicht wegen der Temperaturen,
sondern wegen der Malariamücken,
die v.a. nachts aktiv sind.
Das ist wie hier auch.
Nach Sonnenuntergang kommen sie.
* Zischen der Aludose *
* Eindringliche Klänge *
Sie leben v.a. vom Markt.
Sie bauen Erdnüsse und Bananen an.
Sie haben aber
keine Krankenkasse, nichts.
Licht haben sie keines im Haus,
aber Internet und Handy haben sie.
* Handyklingelton *
Saurer?
Hallo!
Ja.
Mache ich alles, ja.
Ich will noch schauen ...
Weisst du,
ob man Käse mitnehmen kann?
Darf man mitnehmen?
Ja.
Tschüs, Susanne.
Danke. Tschüs, tschüs.
Guten Morgen!- Ja, hallo.
- Salü, Urs.
Wir machen ein kleineres Fest.
Keine Ahnung.
Hey!
Ich dachte, ich muss mich abmelden.
Wieso abmelden?
- Fertig "Surprise".
Was, fertig "Surprise"?
Wir hätten alle nicht geglaubt,
dass du tatsächlich gehst.
Am 19. Dezember
komme ich wieder zurück.
Und jetzt hast du welche
zum Rückkaufen?
Zum Umtauschen, also Zurückgeben.
- Dann machen wir das.
Sie holen dich ab
und du kannst bei ihnen wohnen?
Arbeiten, arbeiten.
Was musst du machen?
Erdnüsse und Bananen.
Bananen ernten?
- Ja.
Wie hast du deinen Flug finanziert?
- V.a. mit "Surprise".
Mit dem Zeitschriftenverkauf?
- Ja. Und vom Overall.
Ich sparte das ganze Jahr
extra dafür.- Wow.
(Mann) Wir hoffen, du kommst zurück.
Ich komme zurück.
Aber nach der Fasnacht
gehe ich vermutlich endgültig.
Darum gehe ich jetzt
nur kurz schauen.
Wie es ist.
* Handyklingelton *
(Mann) Ob es zu viele Schlangen hat.
Ob es wirklich das ist.
* Handyklingelton *
Kamerun ruft: "Urs!"
Die Schlangen, die Schlangen.
Gute Reise!
- Tschüs zusammen.
Mach's gut. Tschüs, tschau, tschau.
* Er hustet. *
* Eindringliche Klänge *
* Bahnhofdurchsage auf Französisch. *
(Durchsage) Tous les passagers
devraient déjâ être à bord.
* Eindringliche Klänge *
"Ich möchte einmal noch,
einmal, das wünsche ich mir ...
... ein freier Mensch sein."
"Ich will nicht,
dass irgendjemand von mir denkt,
ich sei ein armer Tropf."
So, und jetzt überlegen wir,
was wir machen.
Wieder mal füllig ...
- Sie sind megalang.
* Dumpfe, hüpfende Basstöne *
Danke.
Also, ich hätte sie gerne kurz.
- Mhm.
1,5 mm
Das Deckhaar darf etwas fallen,
so wie es ist?- Ja, schon.
Dass ich sie nach hinten kämmen
kann. Du machst das schon.
* Dumpfe, hüpfende Basstöne *
"Plötzlich verstehe ich
die Zusammenhänge."
* Dumpfe, hüpfende Basstöne *
Ich bin zu alt.
Du?
- Ja.
Findest du?
- Ja. Im Berufsleben schon.
* Surren des Haartrimmers *
Ich habe gesoffen, geraucht -
alles, was verboten war.
Das Jugendamt
holte mich von zu Hause weg
und ich kam natürlich
ins Kinderheim.
Ich war so wütend,
als sie mich aus der Wohnung warfen.
Es ist nicht einfach.
- Was meinst du?
Das Leben als Obdachloser
ist nicht einfach.
Ich notiere Sätze von Menschen,
die zu mir kommen.
Sätze von ihnen,
aus dem Leben gegriffen,
was mir von einem Gespräch bleibt.
Es sind so viele Geschichten,
so viele Menschen,
die mir ihre Erlebnisse erzählen.
Es ist mir wichtig geworden,
sie aufzuschreiben.
Anna, du hast die Situation
auf der Gasse zu sein, nie erlebt?
Nein, wirklich nie.
- Gott sei Dank.
Bleibt eine Angst,
dass man wieder ...
Ja, aber man macht sehr viel,
damit es nicht mehr geschieht.
Man kämpft wieder mehr.
Das muss ich mitnehmen.
Die Medis. Uh, das Wichtigste!
Um die Zeit der Obdachlosigkeit
Revue passieren zu lassen,
verbringe ich hin und wieder
eine Nacht am alten Schlafplatz,
um zu wissen, wie es ist.
Ich muss das in Erinnerung rufen,
um das, was ich jetzt habe,
festzuhalten.
Wenn ich nicht an mir arbeite,
falle ich zurück in ein Loch
und lande wieder auf der Strasse -
das will ich nicht mehr.
* Verzerrte Streicherklänge *
Da, wow.
Wahnsinn.
Das haut mich um, ehrlich.
* Strassenlärm, Schritte *
* Sie summt. *
Die Entscheidung,
von zu Hause abzuhauen, wegzugehen?
Das war im Alter von 13.
Ich war 13 Jahre alt.
Mein Stiefvater
missbrauchte mich sexuell.
Irgendwann hält man das
nicht mehr aus.
Ich suchte immer Liebe
an anderen Orten.
Ich war trotz meiner Familie
sehr einsam und allein.
Meine Mutter
entzog mir die Liebe ganz.
So bin ich abgehauen.
- Was ist das für ein Gefühl?
Verachtung!
Man ist Abschaum, ein Stück Dreck.
Man wird nicht geliebt,
muss funktionieren.
Sie drohten mir mit dem Tod.
Meine Mutter sagte: "Wenn du etwas
erzählst, bring ich dich um."
"Und niemand wird dich vermissen."
* Rattern der Kofferräder *
* Glockenschläge *
Wie gehtman damit um,
wie lebt man so?
Man ist allein, kapselt sich ab.
Man kehrt in sich
und vertraut keinem mehr.
Ich wurde misstrauisch
gegen jeden und alles.
Eigentlich hasste ich die Menschen.
Wirklich.
* Dumpfe Klänge *
* Rattern *
* Rascheln *
Zehn, zwölf ...
... 14, 16, 17, 34.
Ich bin dir dankbar,
Jesus Christus von Nazareth,
eine Bleibe im Trockenen zu haben.
(Seufzend) Ich bin schon dankbar.
(Leise) Gute Nacht.
* Schnarchen *
* Husten *
Ich komme da rein,
kriege dieses Bett zugeteilt.
Es stinkt.
Die Leute waschen sich nicht.
Sie sind auch in Not wie ich,
haben keine Wohnung.
Viele haben auch keine Familie,
keinen Job.
Trotzdem muss ich mir einen Ort
aussuchen, der angenehm ist.
Es ist eben nicht angenehm.
* Unverständliche Schreie *
* Die Schreie werden leiser. *
Wenn man wirklich keinen Halt mehr
hat, keine Familie, keine Freunde,
dann wird man mit der Zeit verrückt.
* Er atmet entnervt aus. *
* Eine Eule ruft. *
Es ist ganz anders,
wenn man draussen schläft.
Man hört jedes Geräusch.
Man achtet sich unheimlich.
Nachts, wenn es so ruhig ist,
ist das irre.
Man schaut hinauf
und sieht die Sterne.
Das ist irre.
Durch solche Dinge lernt man
das Leben etwas zu lieben.
* Glockenschlag *
* Surren *
* Piepen *
* Stimmendurcheinander *
Guten Tag miteinander.
Hallo Urs.
- Hallo.
Salü. Zum Glück lebst du noch!
- Ja.
Ja, ja.
Wie geht es dir?
- Soweit wieder gut.
Im Gegensatz zu vorher.
Es war ganz schlimm.
Erzähl mal! Seit deiner Rückkehr aus
Kamerun haben wir uns nicht gesehen.
Nein.
Ich bin eigentlich
gesund zurückgekommen,
zumindest habe ich
noch nichts gemerkt.
Es ist erst
zwei Wochen später gekommen,
dieses Malariazeug.
Aber Kamerun war toll?
- Ja, das war toll.
Das siehst du da auf dem Bild.
Eigentlich
wollte ich für immer gehen.
Ich weiss.- Im August
Du kamst heim und es ging dir gut?
- Ja, zwei Wochen lang.
Dann kam urplötzlich
diese Müdigkeit.
Ich legte mich im Geschäft hin.
Der Arzt sagte,
es wäre noch 2-3 Std. gegangen,
dann wäre fertig gewesen.
Er sagte, bei einem weiteren Stich
würde ich noch
maximal drei Tage leben.
Das heisst eigentlich,
dass du nicht ...
Ich gehe nicht mehr.
Es wird hart sein.
* Eindringliche Musik *
* Piepen des Lifts *
Ich war so schwach
und fühlte mich so mies,
ich wäre am liebsten gestorben.
Ich dachte: "Hoffentlich
nimmt es mit gleich."
Ja, das ist extrem.
Wenn man so weit unten ist,
ist einem alles egal.
Boah!
Und jetzt, was hast du für Pläne?
Vielleicht gehe ich in den Jura.
Mit einer Frau.
Die will dort
eine Pferdepension eröffnen.
Aber lass dir Zeit zum Gesundwerden.
Nein, nein, ich mache sofort weiter.
Je mehr Therapie, je mehr Bewegung,
desto schneller kann ich gehen.
Gartenarbeit
mache ich auch gleich wieder.
Wieso willst du kein Geld
vom Sozialamt beantragen?
Ich will arbeiten.
Ja.
Wenn man wirklich will,
kann man Hilfe bekommen.
In der Schweiz gibt es so viele
Institutionen und Stiftungen.
Aber ich schäme mich
und will das nicht.
Ich bin lieber selbstständig
und niemand muss mir helfen.
Ich bin erwachsen genug
und schaffe das allein.
Fünf hat er gesagt, ja.
Und jetzt mit Vierzigern.
Ich glaube immer noch
an mein Potenzial.
Aber ich habe
nicht immer daran geglaubt.
Als Teenager, mit zwölf, 13, 15
Jahren packte ich es einfach nicht.
Ich hatte vor vielem Angst und fühl-
te mich zu Hause nicht mehr wohl.
Also lief ich über Nacht weg.
Ich glaube, das war, weil ich
keinen richtigen Vater hatte.
* Orgelmusik *
* Surren des Haartrimmers *
Was möchtest du als Vater mitgeben?
Ich erlebe das als Mutter auch.
Wie erziehe ich meine Kinder?
Was kann ich ihnen von mir mitgeben?
Ja.
Ich habe das letzthin
wieder in einem Film gesehen.
Diese innige Vater-Sohn-Beziehung.
Der Sohn wächst,
Jahr für Jahr,
und der Vater
kann nicht da sein,
wegen Karriere, Arbeit und allem ...
Später sieht er, dass er alles
vermasselt hat, verpasst hat.
Und er kann es nie wieder erleben.
Es ist weg für immer, oder.
* Monotone Klänge, Tippen *
* Schnelles Tippen *
Bei welchem Abschnitt des Buches
bist du?
Im Moment zu Hause.
Das Aufwachsen mit den Brüdern,
wie ich nach dem Krankenhaus
heimkomme.
Die Problematik der Sonderschule,
in die ich nach dem
langen Krankenhausaufenthalt kam.
Was macht das Schreiben mit dir?
Für mich ist es gut.
Ich verarbeite es besser.
Aber eben:
Es nagt immer noch an mir.
"Nun, im Augenblick
geht es mir nicht so gut."
"Warum das so ist, habe ich
aber alleine zu verantworten."
"Ich will nicht klagen. Millionen
Menschen geht es wirklich schlecht."
"Diese Woche habe ich
auf eine Weise genossen,
wie ich es eigentlich
gar nicht kenne.
* Schnelles Tippen *
Das ist genau die Kunst.
Ohne Versöhnung mit dem Geschehenen
kann man nicht mehr leben.
Ich lebte nicht, ich funktionierte.
Heute lerne ich, zu leben.
Was Leben heisst,
was man wirklich dazu braucht.
Brauche ich Make-up? Lippenstift
finde ich noch cool für eine Frau.
Eine gewisse Eitelkeit ist noch da.
Das Wertvollste, das man haben kann,
ist ein Mensch an seiner Seite.
Es dauerte sehr lange, bis ich mich
einem Mann wieder öffnen konnte.
Was heisst das? Bist du verliebt?
- Ich bin verliebt.
Ja, aber es dauerte 13 Jahre ...
13 Jahre war ich allein.
* Vogelgezwitscher *
Es ist ein schöner Park.
Zu Beginn auf der Gasse
war ich oft hier.
Nun muss ich langsamer gehen.
Möchtest du zum Geländer?
Oder gehen wir hier rechts runter?
- Nein, runter an den Rhein.
Ich kann heute sagen,
dass ich die Liebe gefunden habe,
auch bei einem Menschen.
Weisst du, was ich möchte?
Ich möchte einmal mit so einem Kahn
den Rhein hoch bis zum Meer.
Das wird schwierig.
- Warum?
Fährst du den Rhein hoch,
kommst du nicht ans Meer.
Du musst runterfahren!
- Stimmt.
(Junge) Kann ich schön werfen?
(Mann) - Ja, der war schön!
Die mag ich auch, weil die täuschen.
Wow!
Hey!
Wenn man dran glaubt,
gibt es immer einen Weg.
Wie gelang es dir,
immer wieder einen Weg zu finden?
Ich glaube, ich kann das
immer noch nicht beantworten.
Ich glaube, es liegt daran,
dass ich mich immer wieder sehe.
Also ... wie ich mich
mir selbst zuwende,
wie wenn man
in einen Spiegel schaut,
richtig tief in die Augen.
Und plötzlich siehst man nicht sich,
also seinen Körper,
sondern sein ganzes Leben.
Und wenn ich mich anschaue,
was ich alles erlebt habe ...
Meine Herkunft, alle Freunde,
die Familie, mein Sohn ...
Wenn ich das alles sehe und auch,
was ich auf diesem Planeten
noch erreichen will,
dann liebe ich mich wieder.
Papa, du musst höher werfen
und fester!
Plötzlich liebt man sich selbst.
Dann fühlt man sich wieder wohler.
Aber es gibt Momente,
in denen man ...
... das nicht kann.
* Schnippeln der Haarschere *
Was machst du,
wenn du es nicht kannst?
Ja, also, keine Ahnung ...
Man lässt sich gehen und sagt sich,
dass man es morgen wieder packt.
"Morgen ist ein anderer Tag",
sage ich oft.
Das WC.
* Stimmengewirr *
Da ist ja ein Bett.
Du kannst erst mal das haben,
dann kriegst du meins,
das ist etwas grösser.- Ja.
- Ja.
Hier ist Ihr Schlüssel.
- Ja, danke.
Einfach nicht verlieren.
- Nein.
Die Küche haben Sie gesehen?
- Ja.
Die teilen Sie
mit drei anderen Personen. - Ja.
Jeder schaut, dass es sauber bleibt.
- Ja.
Nicht wie im Kindergarten:
"Der andere hat ..."
Wer kümmert sich um die Spitex?
Wir hätten jemanden,
der die Klientel kennt.
(Mann) Sie haben den Kontakt
der Sozialhilfe?
Ja. Das läuft, ja.
- Falls etwas wäre ...
Sozialhilfe ...
Ich musste hier rein,
weil ich nichts anderes hatte.
Wirklich glücklich
fühle ich mich da nicht.
Bist du gerne unabhängig?
- Ja.
* Ein Hund bellt. *
Das ist auch bei der Arbeit so.
Und irgendwie allein durchkommen.
Möglichst ohne Hilfe.
- Mhm.
Und wie macht man das?
- Das geht schon, wenn man will.
Man darf einfach nicht sagen:
"Das kann ich nicht."
* Brummende, rhythmische Klänge *
Mir stinkt es,
den ganzen Tag drinnen zu braten.
Irgendwann dreht man durch.
Ja, was soll denn das sein?
Das ist kein Leben, das ist nichts!
Und nirgends arbeiten gehen.
Mhm.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Darf ich ein Nachher-Foto machen?
- Natürlich.
Findest du meine Haare schön so?
Gefällt es dir nicht?
- Doch, ich frag dich!
Ich finde es schön.
- Ich bin zufrieden.
Ja, das ist gut.
Danke schön!
Merci.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Andrea Werlen - 2020